hello
we got together a long time ago we were
talking about how country music should
stop limiting people and start opening
doors it's music brought over from all
over the world the Bluegrass the folks
the gospel there's so many threads woven
through country music
this is my kind of country a music
competition that travels the globe to
break the next country music star
[Music]
we're partnering with three trailblazing
country musicians
Jimmy Allen it took me 11 years to get a
record deal I lived in my car Mickey
Guyton I was the first black female solo
artist to earn a Grammy nomination in a
country category horrible Peck my mask
allows me to be more vulnerable and
share my perspective as a gay country
artist they are going to search the
world for musicians and invite them to
Nashville oh my gosh ultimately there
will be one person who wins a
life-changing prize from Apple music
this is the reason why you let your kids
follow their dreams
got my bag packed here Nashville I'm
coming
[Music]
they say country music is three chords
in the truth it's singing about life and
your life story
myself in English so I sing in Spanish
I struggle with my own inner voice a
little bit but when I get to sing I feel
totally whole that was so sincere and
beautiful and that is country music
just so much potential for something I
don't think anybody's ever seen before
in country music
the people that I love in country music
they don't look like me I'm ready to
show people what they
[Applause]
were
[Music]